اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الحكومه اليمنيه تعلن عن عمليه لتبادل
الاسرى مع الحوثيين في عدن وصنعاء ومناطق
اخرى ولمده ثلاثه ايام
السفير السعودي في اليمن يؤكد بان زيارته
لصنعاء تاتي في اطار تثبيت الهدنه ووقف
اطلاق النار
انطلاق الحمله السعوديه الثالثه للعمل
الخيري والتبرعات تتجاوز ال 470 مليون
ريال
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه ايضا
امانه المدينه المنوره تطلق مختبرا متنقلا
حديثا لفحص سلامه وجوده الاغذيه والمياه
هيئه الاعلام المرئي والمسموع السعوديه
تكشف عن انتاج واحد وثلاثين فيلما سعوديا
منذ 2018
حياكم الله اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه بدء
عمليات تبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين مع
الحوثيين الخميس المقبل ولمده ثلاثه ايام
اشار الفريق الحكومي بالمفاوضات الى ان
عمليات تبادل الاسرى ستشمل رحلات جويه بين
العاصمه صنعاء وعدا ومناطق اخرى في اليمن
بالتنسيق مع لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
كما اكد ان الاستعدادات اكتملت
اليوم الاول وهو طبعا كان المقرر في يوم
عشره وتم تاجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام
بسبب الاجراءات طبعا التي اخذت وقت على
نظرا العدد الكبير عدد الذين من سوف يتم
مبادلتهم تم تعجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام
واليوم الاول سوف يكون
بحسب ما اتفق عليه
يوم طبعا بعد غدا يوم الخميس يوم 13 من
هذا الشهر اول يوم سوف يكون هنالك عمليه
تبادل بين صنعاء وعدن 250
عصير ومختطف
كشف السفير السعودي لدى اليمن والمشرف على
البرنامج السعودي لتنميه واعمار اليمن
محمد الجابر كشف ان زيارته لصنعاء بحضور
وفط عماني هدفها تثبيت الهدنه ووقف اطلاق
النار كما اكد ان العمل جاري في صنعاء
لدعم تبادل الاسرى وبحث سبل الحوار والعمل
على حل سياسي دائما ومستدام في اليمن
السفير السعودي محمد ال جابر شدد ايضا على
وقوف بلاده حكومه وشعبا مع اليمن منذ عقود
في احلك الازمات مشيرا الى ان الجهود
مستمره منذ عام 2011 لتحقيق تطلعات الشعب
اليمني واعاده الامن والاستقرار والازدهار
الاقتصادي الى اليمن
هذا ورحبت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه بجهود
انهاء الحرب في اليمن وزياره السفير
السعودي لصنعاء
قبل حوالي 12 عاما ومنذ اليوم الاول
للازمه في اليمن كانت السعوديه مصدرا
لمبادره الحل سعت في غير ما مره للحفاظ
على هذا البلد موحدا ومستقرا
شكلت الرياض مركزا لاطلاق عديد المبادرات
لجمع شمل اليمنيين لصالح استقرار المنطقه
ورفع المعاناه الانسانيه عن الشعب اليماني
واشنطن سبق واكدت عبر وزير خارجيتها ان
السعوديه اظهرت رغبتها في الوصول الى
اتفاق سلام باليمن
السعوديه اظهرت من خلال افعالها رغبتها في
الوصول الى اتفاق سلام في اليمن وهو امر
ايجابي للغايه
من واشنطن الى باريس استمرت الاشادات
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون من جهته
رحب العام الماضي بجهود السعوديه ودعمها
للهدنه
نشيد بالجهود السعوديه للتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل في اليمن
من جهتها دعمت دوله الامارات جهود
السعوديه لتحقيق حل سياسي للحرب في اليمن
لاحلال السلام ووضع حد دائم للاعمال
العدائيه بين جميع الاطراف اليمنيه
المختلفه
فالرياض وحدت المكونات اليمنيه في المجلس
الرئاسي واستطاعت انهاء الخلافات التي
عطلت عمل المجلس خلال الاشهر الماضيه
التواصل او الاتصال بين الشقه المركبه
السعوديه والحوثيين المملكه لم تغلق بابها
مطلقا طوال سنوات الحرب كانت دائما
المملكه يعني اي باب ينفتح في هذا المجال
سواء بشقه السياسي او بشقه الامنيين كان
دائما يظل الباب مفتوح وكان الرساله
الرئيسيه نحن
اي فرصه ستتيح لنا
ان نجمع اليمنيين ان نقدم اي محفزات
الجانب الحوثي حتى ياتي الى الطاوله سنقوم
بهذا الامر هي اذا شعله امل جديده او
قدتها الرياض بعد محاولات عديده لانهاء
حاله الاستقرار في هذا البلد العربي سيرا
في طريق السلام بلال البشتين العربيه
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا الاكاديمي المتخصص
في العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور هشام الغنام دكتور هشام مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض بدايه ما الذي تقراه في تواجد
الوفد السعودي برئاسه السفير الجابر في
صنعاء هل يمكن القول باننا امام سياسه
سعوديه جديده في اليمن تجنب الحرب تقرب
السلم بين الفرقاء اليمنيين ام هناك قراءه
اخرى
هذا من الجهه السعوديه لكن من الجهه
اليمنيه انا اعتقد انه ايضا باختلاف
مكونات الشعب اليمني وبتعقيد المشهد على
الارض بدون دور سعودي في اليمن لن تحل
الازمه
يعني اذكر كلام يعني قبل بدايه هذا الحرب
بعد بدايتها والسعوديه تعلن في اكثر
مناسبه ان هدفها اتفاق اليمنيين وسندعم
هذا بكل قدراتنا يعني حتى ترى من يهاجم
السعوديه تجده يطلب تدخلها ايضا في نفس
الوقت ولا يناشد الا هي انا اعتقد ان هذا
قدر المملكه المحتوم اليمن ولابد ان ترفع
المملكه بهذا
الدور بعض المحللين ينظر لواقع المنطقه
دكتور هشام اليوم بانه اتجاه لاحد بنود ما
يسمى بالعقيده الاوباميه تحديدا ضروره
تقاسم النفوذ في المنطقه
بين السعوديه وايران تحديدا هل هناك حاليا
ما يبرر هذه التحليلات او يدلل عليها من
خلال استشرافك للموضوع
هذا اعتقد العموميات غير مفيده يعني
النفوذ يعني اولا تحرير مصطلح ماذا يعني
نفود النفود اولا مكلف وانا اعتقد انا
برايي الشخصي ان المملكه لا تنافس على
النفود من يريد النفود فليتحمل كل فتره
فلياخذه يعني النفود مكلف ومتعب ومرهق ولا
اعتقد ان في احد يريد استنساخ النموذج
الايراني الداخلي في اي مكان اخر في
المنطقه انا اعتقد النفوذ المطلوب ياتي في
مستويات مختلفه نعتقد نفوذ المطلوب
والتدخل الاقتصادي هذا التدخل اقتصادي
التدخل الناعم ياتي بكل شيء اخر يعني
المملكه تنافس على فرص اقتصاديه اما صراع
مكلف غير مجدي فانا اعتقد من يريده
فلياخذه يعني المملكه لديها رؤيه نهضويه
شامله ليس فقط داخل حدودها ايضا خارج
حدودها اما هذا النفوذ والصراع النفوذ
وهذه النظريات انا لا اعتقد انها مفيده
ولا عمليه لا لنا ولا لغيرنا في المنطقه
نحن ايضا نتمنى نتمنى ان يتعدل الوضع يعني
اسمح لي بس اختلف على الموضوع انه مبدئي
هو قد يكون مبدئي في شكله لكن انا اعتقد
انها
ان اكثر من ذلك انا اعتقد اولا
نعم انا اعتقد نوفر الارضيه المناسبه
ومن يقول لان هذا
لم يحدث انا اعتقد انه ان هذا كلام غير
دقيق اعتقد ما حدث وانتصار دبلوماسي اولا
المملكه بهذه الصفقه واعتقد انتصار
الدبلوماسيه المملكه النشطه
الصراعات وفي هذا التوقيت بالتاكيد وانا
اسمع ايضا ترى حتى يعني من داخل المنطقه
يعني وليس من خارجها يعني ليس لها علاقه
ان في مفاهمات مع الحوثيين من فتره طويله
مع سوريا صحيح هذا واقع فعلا لكن طبعا هذا
الكلام ايضا يتعارض في بعض اجزاءه مع
الثابت بالدليل التهدئه مع ايران تنعكس
فورا على كافه مناطق التوتر في المنطقه
وهذا لا يتعارض لان المحادثات والقنوات
السريه مفتوحه
ومستمره مع جميع اطراف الازمه سواء في
اليمن او غير اليمن يعني السعوديه يعني
تعمل على اكثر من جبهه وانا اعتقد الان
فيها في نجاحات ينبغي البناء عليها
والاستثمار فيها بشكل اكبر والمنطقه مقبله
على مرحله من التفاعل اتمنى اتمنى ان اجيب
الاطراف تنتهي بالنسبه لعمل السعوديه
لاكثر من جبهه كما قلت اين يمكن ان نضع
الملف اليمني اليوم في استراتيجيه
السعوديه لبناء السلام في المنطقه بشكل
عام دكتور هشام او بالتاكيد بالقطع ياتي
في مقدمه توليات المملكه المحيطه المباشر
ولا والاقرب هي اليمن
يعني بدون سلام في اليمن وبدون تهدئه وكما
قلت انا استقرار وازدهار في اليمن نحن لا
نريد فقط ان اليمن يكون مستقرا نريد اليمن
ان يكون مزدهرا بدون نهضه اقتصاديه في
اليمن بدون حل الازمه الانسانيه في اليمن
اكيد المصالح السعوديه مهدده يعني هم هم
هم هم بقعه استراتيجيه في المنطقه للمملكه
هي بالتاكيد اليمن وهذا يعني
انا اعتقد يعني بالامكان ربطه ايضا بملفات
اخرى بس اذا وضعنا سلم لترتيب الاولويات
لا شك ان اليمن ياتي في مقدمتها ولا تنافس
عليه اي دوله اخرى وزير الخارجيه الايراني
عبد الهيان كان قد عبر في وقت سابق اتذكر
كان هذا في مؤتمر صحفي مع وزير الخارجيه
الروسي قال في بانه
يرحبون بوقف الحرب كذلك ايضا حتى تمديد
الهدنه او الحل السياسي في اليمن هل ترى
هذا ايجابي الى حد انه دفع الحوثيين الى
التجاوب مع الجهود السعوديه مع الجهود
الامميه ايضا حتى كذلك
لغلق ملف الحرب في اليمني نهائيا ام لا
هذا الموقف ربما يكون
بعدا تكتيكيا
اخر يعني له قراءه مختلفه تماما
هو تقريبا كل هذا لكن اسمح لي انا احرر
بعض التفاصيل فيه بالطبع اولا هو موقف
ايجابي واي جهود وتصريحات في هذا لا شك
انها مرحب بها خاصه من الايرانيين الان
يبقى السؤال هل لهذا ابعاد تكتيكيه انا
اعتقد بالتاكيد نعم يعني ما كان يطلق على
المملكه
وهذا التصعيد الذي كان يحدث في اليمن
والسلاح الذي في اليمن ليس مصنعا في احد
كهوف اليمن هو ياتي من مكان اخر
لكن ايضا
الكل يجب ان يرحب بدعم ايران لاي مسار
ايجابي في اليمن لكن هذا الدعم سواء من
الاخوه في ايران لاي محادثات سلام في
اليمن
يعني ممكن تفسيرها بانه يكون من خلال
الضغط على الحوثي للتخفيف حجه بعض
استفزازات لكنه لا ينبغي اذا اعتقد تفسيرا
انه استعداد من ايران لتخلي عن اداه قوتها
هناك يعني هذا ما يجعل اليمن معقدا انا
اعتقد ان ايران لا زالت ولفتره طويله
ستعتبر اليمن ممر استراتيجي لها يضمن لها
مكانا مهما في جزيره العرب خلال اي نزاع
افتراضي او مستقبلي انا لا اتوقع ان لا
تتخلى عن هذا بسهوله ستستخدمها ايضا في
فرض عبء لوجستي على جيران اليمن وهذه جزء
من خريطه يعني هذا ليس سرا جزء من خريطه
رد ايران في المنطقه
اذا عرفنا لذلك النيران ايضا
ترى المملكه تهديد عسكري في صعود خطير
بالنسبه لها هذا طبعا في السابق قبل هذه
الاتفاقيه بينهما انا والتخطيط العسكري
الايراني يضع هذا في حسبانه
اذا لم تتطور العلاقه بين السعوديه وايران
وهذا سيتطلب وقتا
بشكل يعني الكل يرجوه فهذه المعادله ستبقى
معنا لفتره ليست بالقصيده ونحن نريد انها
تنتهي الكل يريد الملف اليمني كما ذكرت
دكتور هشام هو ملفي يبدو معقد الى حد كبير
بالنظر الى يمكن محاور ومستويات الصراع
الرئيسيه بين الشرعيه الحوثيين ايضا كذلك
بين الشمال الجنوب ايضا تعدد مراكز القوى
السياسيه والقبليه كذلك في الشمال
اختلافات عدد المكونات الجنوبيه ايضا
واختلافها كيف يمكن قراءه كل هذه
الاختلافات تاثيرها على اي عمليه سلام وحل
محتمل في اليمن خلال الايام القادمه دكتور
اكيد هذه كلها تعقيدات عندنا ولا يجب ان
احد يقلل من صعوباتها وصعوبه حلها لكن
الامور تؤخذ على مراحل وتؤخذ بشكل متدرج
عندنا ازمه وكارثه انسانيه في اليمن سواء
كانت الازمه في مناطق الحكومه الشرعيه او
في مناطق سيطره انصار الله هذا لابد ان
يحل استقرار اليمن انا كما قلت اولويه
بالنسبه للمملكه لا تسبقه اليه اي دوله
اخرى في الجوار خروج اليمن من هذه الازمه
هو هدف سعودي مباشره الان لابد من ان يعني
يخرج اليمن بدايه من نادي الازمه ثم يعني
يحدث هذا الحل السياسي الشامل الذي كل
يرجوه طبعا في صعوبات وفي ازمه ثقه وفي
مشاكل كثيره والكل مسلح لكن يعني ما
نرجعوه الحقيقه يعني ان يتحلل الجميع
بالعقل والحكمه وان يقدم مصلحه اليمن ككل
يعني عموم الاراضي اليمنيه ان احنا نستثني
احدا من الحقيقه لابد ان تحل هذه الازمه
والكل له حق الكل له حق
يطالب به لكن في طرق المطالبه به لان هذا
لن يقدم احدا لن يتنازل طرف اذا لم يتنازل
الطرف الاخر هذا الحقيقه يعني حوار يمني
يمني المملكه وبقيه ايضا في الجهد الدولي
يدعم هذا وانا اتمنى ايضا ان من كان يدعم
الحوثي او غير الحوثي ان يدخل في هذه
المساله حتى لو اراد الحفاظ على مصالحه
يعني عندنا ازمه في اليمن وازمه انسانيه
بالدرجه الاولى لابد ان تحل لابد ان تحل
باي شكل وهذا هو هدف السعودي المباشر الان
على المدى القصير والمدى البعيد كذلك
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض انضم الينا
الاكاديميه المتخصص في العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور هشام الغنام شكرا
دكتور هشام
الرابعه المستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
امانه المدينه المنوره تطلق مختبرا متنقلا
حديثا لفحص سلامه وجوده الاغذيه والمياه
حياكم الله من جديد دشنا نائب وامير منطقه
مكه المكرمه الامير بدر بن سلطان طريق
الملك عبد العزيز المؤقت وطريق الدائري
الاول حيث تم افتتاح طريق الملك عبد
العزيز بمكه المكرمه بطوله
ثلاثه وخمسه باكثر من ثلاثه كيلو مترات
وبعرض اربعين متر بشكل مؤقت واستثنائي
لحين اكتمال اعمال البنيه التحتيه للوجه
وياتي ذلك تحقيقا انسيابيه الحركه
المروريه لضيوف المسجد الحرامي وزوار
وسكان مدينه مكه المكرمه خلال ايام شهر
رمضان
اكثر من 93% انجزت من انشاء البنيه
التحتيه في مشروع مسار مكه ما سمح بافتتاح
الطرق الرئيسيه بالمشروع لتسهيل الحركه
المروريه الكثيفه للمصلين والمعتمرين في
العشر الاواخر من شهر رمضان
اقف الان فوق احدى اسطح مباني مواقف
السيارات والتي تستوعب 5600 سياره وستدعم
كثيرا انسيابيه الحركه من والى المسجد
الحرام
طريق الملك عبد العزيز الجنوبي والشمالي
في مسار مكه افتتح بشكل مؤقت واستثنائي
الى حين اكتمال اعمال البنيه التحتيه
للوجهه التي ستضيف تسعه مليارات ريال
للناتج المحلي لمكه
سينشط كثيرا هذا الطريق الذي تم افتتاحه
ضمن مشروع مسار مكه وايضا الطريق الاخر
المخصص للقادمين الى المسجد الحرام
وسيرتبط بشبكه الطرق بمكه المكرمه لتخفيف
الازدحام
هذا المشروع الضخم الذي تبلغ مساحه اراضيه
التطويريه ال 690 الف متر مربع يهدف
لتوفير عشرات الاف الغرف الفندقيه عبر
المشاريع الفندقيه لاستيعاب العدد
المتزايد من المعتمرين الذين تستهدف
السعوديه رفع اعدادهم الى 30 مليون معتمرا
بحلول عام 2030
من مكه المكرمه نواف عزيز العربيه
اطلقت الغرفه التجاريه بمكه المكرمه
النسخه الاولى من منتدى منافع الذي يعد
احد المشاريع المترجمه لاهداف الاتفاقيه
المترجمه لاهداف الاتفاقيه ثلاثيه منافع
التي جمعت غرفه مكه والمدينه المنوره
والغرفه الاسلاميه
يعني هذه المبادره راح يعني انها تستقطب
التجاره على مستوى العالم والمستوى العالم
الاسلامي زي ما قلنا للمكانه الاسلاميه
لمكه والمدينه طبعا من ضمن المستهدفات
لهذه المبادره تسعه محاور من بعض هذه
المحاور هو اقامه معرض دائم للتبادل
الاسلامي او تبادل السلع الاسلاميه في هذا
المعرض الدائم الذي سيكون ان شاء الله في
مكه المكرمه
اطلق ثمنه منطقه المدينه المنوره اعمال
المختبر المتنقل الخاص بفحص جوده وسلامه
الاغذيه والمياه للتاكد من خلوها من
البكتيريا المسببه للامراض
ومطابقتها للمواصفات بهدف ضمان سلامه
وجوده الغذاء المقدم لاهالي وزوار المدينه
المنوره طوال شهر رمضان ويضم المختبر
المتنقل اجهزه حديثه لفحص المواد الغذائيه
في وقت قياسي
[موسيقى]
سلامه الاغذيه والمشروبات اولويه تزيد
اهميتها خلال شهر رمضان وفي خطوه للحد من
تلوث الاطعمه فعلت اماله المدينه المنوره
المختبره المتنقله للتاكد من سلامتها
هو عباره عن سياره مزوده باحدث التقنيات
لفحص الملوثات الميكروبيه والكيميائيه
الموجوده في الاغذيه يتم فيه فحص تقريبا
1500 تعينه في الشهر يتم سحبها عبر فرق
رقابيه مختصه
احضاره للمختبر يتم عليها عمل الفحوصات
اللازمه لكل نوع الهدف طبعا من المختبر
المتنقل هو
الحفاظ على سلامه المواطنين والزوار
وتوفير الامان الغذائي لهم اكثر من مئه
عينه تسحب يوميا من 50 محلا تجاريا للكشف
عليها ويضم المختبر المتنقل اجهزه حديثه
لفحص المواد الغذائيه في وقت قياسي وضمان
خلوها من البكتيريا المسببه للامراض
ومطابقتها للمواصفات الاخت التي يتم فحصها
في المختبر المتنقل نتائجها تظهر فوريا
بمجرد سحب العينه ووضعها في الجهاز يعطي
نتائج سريعه ودقيقه طبعا احنا قلنا بحملات
توعويه وضحنا لهم الطريقه السليمه لتنظيف
الايدي وزعنا عليهم معقمات خمسه اختبارات
يجريها المختبر المتنقل مثل الكشف عن
عناصر الحديد والكبريت في المياه اضافه
الى السموم الفطريه ومتبقيه المبيدات في
الاغذيه والهدف حياه امنه غذائيا لسكان
وزوار المدينه المنوره من المدينه المنوره
سلطان السلمي العربيه
يشهد مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
حركه تشغيليه مرتفعه مع بدء العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان حيث بلغ عدد الرحلات القادمه
الى المطار وللمغادره منه اكثر من 13 الف
رحله منذ مطلع شهر رمضان وحتى اليوم
ووسط اجراءات للطوارئ والتدخل السريع
العربيه يلتحق بنا بالمطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده نواف مساء الخير مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وخلينا
نتحدث اولا عن اجراءات مركز
القياده والتحكم للتعامل مع طبعا الاعداد
الكبيره القادمه الى مطار الملك عبد
العزيز في جده خصوصا في العشر الاواخر
والاعداد الهائله ايضا من المسافرين واذا
كان في ارقام المسافرين تسودنا فيها
اهلا نايف تحدي كبير يمر به مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي في جده مع هذه الاعداد
المليونيه من المسافرين من المعتمرين
وقاصدي المسجد الحرام ربما هذا المطار لم
يشهد منذ افتتاحه في عام 2019 هذه الاعداد
الكبيره حتى الان منذ بدايه رمضان بلغ عدد
المسافرين اكثر من مليونين مسافر حتى هذه
اللحظه سواء من القادمين او حتى الرحلات
المغادره هنا في مركز التحكم كما تشاهدون
من خلف العديد من المهام التي يعمل عليها
هذا المركز وهو يعتبر القلب النابض لمطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده هذا
المطار الذي يعتمد كثيرا على مثل هذه
المراكز للتحكم والارتباط مع الجهات
الحكوميه 27 جهه حكوميه وايضا الجهات
الخاصه والجهات التشغيليه ترتبط بهذا
المركز الذي ايضا يتلقى البلاغات يتعامل
معها يراقب بشكل
لحظي حركه المسافرين
خطوط السير الامتعه وايضا يتابع عمليات
تزويد الطائرات بالوقود واداره المرافق
والعديد من المهام الاخرى لضمان سير
العمليه التشغيليه وفق الخطط التي وضعتها
اداره مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في
جده لمواكبه هذه الحركه الكبيره ثلاثه
اكثر من ثلاثه عشر الف مسافر خلال الايام
العشر القادمه في العشر الاواخر من رمضان
ستتزايد هذه الاعداد بشكل كبير جدا كما هو
متوقع مع العديد من التسهيلات هنا ايضا
عمليات النقل
نقاط التوقف للحافلات وبوابات ايضا
للحافلات وثلاث الصالات مخصصه لاستقبال
المعتمرين والزوار بمساحه تصل الى مليون
و300 الف متر مربع تستوعب بشكل يومي 130
الف معتمر على مدار اليوم حقيقه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم نلاحظ تسجيل اي حالات سواء تكدس
او اعاقه في حركات السير او المسافرين منذ
بدايه رمضان وهذا ربما يعطي مرحله جديده
لمطار الملك عبد العزيز بعد بعض المشاكل
التي حدثت خلال السنوات الماضيه من تكدس
والعديد من المشاكل الاخرى ولكن ربما
تعتبر هذه مرحله جديده مع هذه الاعداد
الكبيره من المعتمرين
والزوار المسجد الحرام ومكه المكرمه واي
حتى المدينه المنوره لا زلنا في بدايه
العشر الاواخر الاعداد ستتزايد بشكل كبير
جدا خلال الايام القادمه
والخطط التشغيليه لمطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي من خلال مركز التحكم وايضا الخطط
الموضوعه ستعمل بشكل دقيق لمراجعه اي
اعمال لدعم هذه الحركه الكبيره في المطار
من المسافرين من المعتمرين من مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز شكرا جزيلا لك نواف
في مكه عملت لاداره العمل لمشروع الملك
عبد الله لسقيا زمزم على رفع الجاهزيه في
المشروع بشكل كامل وذلك استعداد لاستقبال
الطلب المتزايد على ماء زمزم من قبل
المعتمرين والزوار خلال شهر رمضان تصل
الطاقه الانتاجيه للمشروع لاكثر من 200
الف عبوه يوميا كما يحو توي على مستودعات
استراتيجيه بمواصفات ومعايير تتضمن سلامه
عبوات مياه زمزم وبطاقه استيعابيه تصل الى
مليونين و200 الف عبوه
من مكه المكرمه يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه مساء الخير حياك الله
معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض وخلينا
نعرف اولا يعني اليه وخطط العمل في هذا
المصنع سقيا زمزم خلال شهر رمضان كيف
تختلف عن بقيه الاشهر
اهلا وسهلا نايف تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدي العربيه مع منقل لكم صوت الصوره
اليوم من هنا من مشروع الملك عبد الله
لسقي زمزم كما اسبقنا هناك اكثر من
مليونين و200 الف عبوه في مستودعات هذا
المشروع كما يتم انتاج اكثر من 200 الف
عبوه يوميا طبعا نلحظ الان عبر الكاميرا
العربيه كيف يتم طلب المياه من قبل
المستفيدين يدخل هنا ببطاقه هويتي او
بطاقه الاقامه ثم ياخذ ورقه يذهب بها الى
شاشات العرض وهناك عدد من الشاشات تصل الى
تسع شاشات عرض ياخذ منها ورقه ويتم الدفع
من خلالها طبعا يحق للمستفيد طلب عشرين
عبوه بالشهر تزيد او تنقص على حسب الظروف
الموجوده في المشروع نتحدث ايضا عن
الارقام الكبيره جدا التي تتواجد اليوم في
هذا المشروع ثم ينتقل الى محطه اخرى هي
محطه التوزيع طبعا يسعدني الان ان يكون
معي والوكيل مساعد الرئيس
الحرمين وايضا الامين اللجنه الاشرافيه
لمشروع سقيا زمزم الدكتور عبد الرحمن
الخطابي سهل فيك دكتور ابتداء حدثني اليوم
انه احنا اليوم نتكلم في هذا المشروع
مليونين و200 الف عبوه موجوده في المستودع
والمصنع ايضا كيف يتم رفع الطاقه
التشغيليه واستيعابيه في شهر رمضان
المبارك وتحديدا انهم مقبلون الان على
العشر الاواخر في رمضان اولا نرحب بكم كل
الترحيب بكم وبالسعاده المشاهدين بفضل من
الله واستعدادا لموسم رمضان وجه معالي
رئيس اللجنه الاشرافيه الشيخ الدكتور عبد
الرحمن بن عبد العزيز السديس بتنفيذ الخطه
التشغيليه لموسم رمضان والعشر الاواخر
والتي اشتملت على
نقطتين النقطه الاولى ايصال او امداد
الحرمين الشريفين بميات بمياه زمزم كافيه
وكذلك
ايصال مع زمزم لطالبيه بشكل المطلوب في
بيئه في في عبوات صحيه امنه وبكل يسر
بسهوله نتحدث الان ايضا دكتور عبد الرحمن
ونحن نلحظ ايضا الان نقاط التوزيع واخذ
المستفيدين لعبوات مياه زمزم عبر عربات
مخصصه ومجموعات موزعه لهذه المنطقه كيف
استعديتهم اليوم في المشروع لاستقبال هذه
الاعداد الكبيره جدا نحن نتحدث اليوم عن
اعداد مليونيه لزوار وقاصدين مسجد الحرام
ناهيك ايضا عن الاعداد المتواجده اليوم
الذين يطلبون ايضا من المواطنين المقيمين
في مكه المكرمه كيف استعديتهم لهذه
المرحله بفضل من الله يشتمل المشروع على
مخزن استراتيجي سعته اثنين مليون و200 الف
عبوه كذلك الطاقه الانتاجيه القصوى لليوم
لليوم الواحد 200 الف عبوه هذه باذن الله
يعني
نستطيع ان نقول انها تؤمن ما زمزم لقصده
وخصوصا لطالبيه وخصوصا في العشر الاواخر
حيث يدار هذا المشروع من قبل شركه المياه
الوطنيه
باشراف من اللجنه الاشرافيه لم الملك عبد
الله سقيا زمزم هذه اللجنه مشكله بقرار
وساري يراسها معالي الرئيس العامل المسجد
الحرام والمسجد النبوي وعضويه وزاره الحج
وكذلك وزاره البيئه والمياه وهيئه المساحه
الجيولوجيه والرئاسه العامه المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي وشركه المياه الوطنيه وعضو
او ممثل من القطاع الخاص يقومون باعتماد
استراتيجيه المشروع وحكامته وكذلك متابعه
تنفيذ الخطط التشغيليه وخصوصا المرتبطه
بالمواسم كموسم رمضان دكتور عبد الرحمن
وانت الامين اللجنه الاشرافيه هنا في
مشروع الملك عبد الله شكرا لك اذا اتحدث
اليوم نايف عن عدم تاثر هذه الحركه في
مسائل التوزيع ايضا وبيع هذه العبوات
مليونين و200 الف عبوه موجوده الان في
المستودع ياخذها المستفيدون بين فتره او
اخرى كما اشار الدكتور عبد الرحمن ليست
هناك اي حالات تذكر لموضوع انه تتاثر هذه
العمليه نعم الطلب متزايد ولكن هذه
الحالات تتاثر نشهد ايضا تواجد الكثير
اليوم من الزوار والمعتمرين وقاصدين
المسجد الحرام بعد انتهاء من اداء مناسكهم
يتم مباشره لاخذ مياه زمزم ناهيك ايضا عن
اخذ المواطنين المقيمين هنا في مكه
المكرمه ايضا حتى في المناطق الاخرى من
هذه الخدمه الموجوده هنا في كدي من مكه
المكرمه مراسل العربيه وسام القاسم شكرا
جزيلا لك
اشاره الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
ايضا
منشات السعوديه تطلق برنامجا للشركات
المتسارعه النمو بشراكه مع وادي السيليكون
في الولايات المتحده
حياكم الله من جديد اطلقت الهيئه العامه
للمنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه في السعوديه
بالتعاون مع وادي السيليكون للابتكار في
الولايات المتحده اطلقت برنامج نمو لدعم
قيادات المنشات في تطوير مهاراتها
القياديه وذلك عن طريق برنامج مكثف يتم
تقديمه بمشاركه مجموعه من الخبراء
المتخصصين في مجال رياده الاعمال لمساعده
قياده المنشاه لنمو التوسع باستخدام افضل
الممارسات العالميه حيث يستهدف البرنامج
50 منشاه خلال ثلاثه اشهر
من الرياض انضموا الينا مدير اداره برامج
نمو المنشات في الهيئه العامه للمنشات
الصغيره والمتوسطه سامي الوحدات سيد سامي
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياضه
خلينا نحكي اولا بتفاصيل اكثر اذا سمحت عن
هذا البرنامج الذي اطلقته منشات
ابرز ما تستهدفونه ايضا من هذا البرنامج
طيب حياك الله اخوي نايف المشاهدين
المشاهدات كما العربيه على هذه الاستضافه
طبعا برنامج
من ضمن برامج النمو العالميه المقدمه تحت
مظله مبادره طموح التابعه لهي العامل
المتوسطه
تم اطلاق البرنامج باشتراك مع مركز
الابتكار في وادي السيليكون وهو مركز
استشاري في مجال الابتكار متخصص في
التعليم وتحول والابحاث وتعمل على مدى
سنوات طويله مع انشاء الصين متوسطه في
يعني تنفيذ مشاريع لدفع نموها وربط هذه
المنشات مع الكبرى واصحاب التجارب في وادي
السيليكون البرنامج هو عباره عن مجموعه من
الجلسات الاستشاريه العمل والمحاضرات
والانشطه تستمر تقريبا لمده 12 اسبوع
وبعدد ساعات تتجاوز 80 ساعه يركز البرنامج
بشكل اساسي على تنميه المهارات القياديه
والمعرفيه والابتكاريه لدى قيادات المنشات
والمشاركه وفي مجالات متنوعه الرقمي
والاستراتيجيه
وشراكات مبيعات بشكل الشركات المستهدفه
للمشاركه فيها البرنامج
الشركات المستهدفه هي الشركات
متسارعه النمو الشركات السعوديه متسارعه
النمو نعرفها بمشاعات اللي يكون عندها نمو
في الايرادات والتوظيف بنسب عشرين في
المئه اكثر لاخر ثلاث سنوات طبعا يمكن
لمشاهده هذه الاستفاده من هذا البرنامج من
خلال تقديم طلب الانضمام لطموح
وسيتم مراجعه الطلب ومطابقه المعايير
واشعار الشعب ممتاز على ذكر البرنامج ايضا
حتى طموح المبادرات التي تقدمونها ايضا
كذلك للمنشات في طموح كيف يمكن الحديث
عنها طبعا طموح هو بشكل اساسي في نايف
ومجتمع لمشاهده متوسطه مسار في المملكه
عندنا حاليا تقريبا اكثر من 25 خدمه وثلاث
برامج دوليه كلها تصب يعني تقدم ثلاث
مجالات رئيسيه
الصوره الاسواق من خلال توسع الدولي
والوصول للتمويل من خلال تجهيز المنشات
الطرح في السوق في السوق الاسهم وكذلك
المحور الثالث للوصول الى المعرفه من خلال
فرش العمل
وجلسات ارشاد يقدمها خبراء من شبكات خبره
عالميه مثل جي اف جي
اليوم انا يعني دخلت على
المتصفح يعني لهذا البرنامج طموح وجدت انه
في في عدد من الشروط
للتسجيل ايضا سامي السيد سامي هل تستطيع
اجازه ابرز هذه الشروط لماذا وضعت ايضا
كذلك حتى هذه الشروط
طبعا لما نتكلم على مبادره طموح شروط
الانضمام لها واضحه مثل ما ذكرت ان يكون
في نمو في الايرادات او في التوظيف لهذه
المنشاه بنسبه 20% فاكثر لاخر ثلاث سنوات
متتابعه
هذا الشيء الاساسي مش تكون ابتكاريه قادره
على انها يعني يكون عندها توسع او قدره
يكون عندها النمو
لدى قيادات هذه المنشات رغبه في معرفه
المستجدات
التقنيه في مجال التحول الرقمي وغيرها من
المجالات هذا الشرط الاساسي عندنا الله
يسلمك وبامكان المنشاه مثل ما ذكرت تقدم
على الطلب والاستفاده من البرنامج
والخدمات الاخرى ايضا في برنامجكم
بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك
من الرياض انضم الينا مدير اداره برامج
نمو المنشات في الهيئه العمل المنشاه
الصغيره والمتوسطه السيد سامي الوحدان
في عامها الثالث عشر تستمر حمله افطار
علينا عبر اذاعه بانوراما اف ام بشراكه مع
البنك الاهلي وبنش مارك في توزيعه وجبات
الافطار على الصائمين وتهدف الحمله التي
تبدا مع بدايه شهر رمضان كل عام وتستمر
طوال الشهر خلال وقت الاذان الى توزيع
مئات وجبات افطار للصائمين يوميا في ثلاث
مدن رئيسيه وهي الرياض وجده والدمه
قبل دقائق معدوده من الافطار هنالك الكثير
من الاشخاص لا زالوا في الشارع بينما
يستعد هؤلاء المتطوعين لتقديم وجبات
الافطار للكثير ممن لم يستطيعوا اللحاق
بسفر اهاليهم وهذا ضمن حمله استمرت لسنوات
من المتطوعين وايضا من عدد من الجهات التي
تقوم بها الاستاذ رامي يحدثنا عن هذه
الحمله حدثنا اكثر عن هذه الحمله بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الانبياء والمرسلين طبعا احنا سعداء من
البنك الاهلي بخدمه المجتمع وتقديم وجبات
الافطار لهم بالاضافه الى ذلك تقديم
التوعيه المروريه وحثهم على عدم السرعه
حمله سعاده حمله افطار الصائم البنك
الاهلي بيقدمها منذ 13 سنه تقريبا والحمله
هذه تهدف زي ما ذكرنا الافطار الصائمين
وحتى ما لعدم السرعه وهي عباره عن جزء من
حمله اكبر وهي حمله سعاده اهالينا والتي
يهدف البنك دائما فيها الاسعاده افراد
المجتمع الذين نرى انهم فعلا اهالونا
رفع الاذان لصلاه المغرب وبدا الجميع في
الافطار لكن المتطوعين لازالوا في الميدان
يقومون بتوزيع عمليات او وجبات الافطار
لكل من لم يستطع الذهاب الى اهله في هذه
اللحظه معي فهد هو مسؤول المتطوعين فهد ما
الذي يدفع المتطوعين للقيام بهذا العمل
وترك وجبات الافطار لذيذه في سفر في بيوت
اهاليهم وسفرهم اولا صراحه بودي نشكر
القائمين على الحمله يعني يا رب لك الحمد
اكثر من 13 سنه مده الحمله من اف ام لبنك
الاهلي ومسؤوليه المسؤوليه المجتمعيه
وايضا القائمين على تنفيذها شركه علاقاته
وبنش مارك فشكر لهم على هالحمله والمبادره
بالنسبه للدافع الاساسي اعتقد ان الاجر
والتجربه وشعور او لذه العطاء في العمل
اللي جالس تقوم فيه كمتطوع يعني الابتسامه
الدعاء اللي واحنا جالسين نمد الوجبه
للصائمين اثر عظيم جدا على النفس تشعر
بطمانينه بسعاده الدعوه الجميله هذه كلها
حوافز واثار ترجع عليك بالايجاب بلا شك
تعملوا هذه الحمله توازيا في ثلاثه مدن
سعوديه وبنفس التوقيت في الرياض هنا وايضا
في جده بالاضافه الى الدمام ويعمل فيها
ايضا الاف المتطوعين او مئات المتطوعين
الذين يوزعون الاف الوجبات يوميا على
الصائمين في الطرقات عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه الرياض
السعوديه ارتفع اجمالي التبرعات ضمن
الحمله الوطنيه للعمل الخيري الثالثه الى
اكثر من 470 مليون ريال وذلك خلال الساعات
الاولى من انطلاق الحمله الخيريه من
الافراد والشركات والمصارفين وتشمل الحمله
ست مجالات منها التعليميه والاجتماعيه
والصحيه تعمل من خلال بنيه الرقميه تعزز
من انقطاع الخيري السعودي
تعمل المنصه على التاكد من هذه الاحتياجات
وبحث المبادرات والمشاريع واليوم منصه
احسان تجاوزت 14 الف مشروع وفرصه نشرتها
على المنصه وعملت مع اكثر من الف جمعيه
على مستوى المملكه مئه بالمئه من هذه
الجمعيات تجاوز مستوى الحوكمه وتتاكد
المنصه اليوم من تنفيذ هذه المشاريع بما
يعكس حياه على المستفيد
ويقلل من احتياجه يوما بعد يوم واليوم
منصه اليوم بحمد الله خدمت اربعه ملايين
وثمانم
[موسيقى]
ئه الاعلام المرئي والمسموع في السعوديه
عن انتاج وعرض 31 في السينمائيا سعوديا
منذ افتتاح السينما في العام 2018 وذلك
دعما لصناعه السينما المحليه والتنويع
مصادر الدخل والترفيه الهيئه السعوديه
كشفت ايضا عن اكثر من خمسه افلام سعوديه
حضورا في صلاه سينما تصدرهم فيلم ستار
محققا مبيعات قاربت مليونير تذكره من
الاخير اداره اعمال المصارعين سيارات توتن
لوس تسمع
قولي لامك ان المطبخ
بيجيه وخلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا موسم
الاذرعه ومدته 26 يوما التفاصيل في تقويم
مع خالد السعد
[موسيقى]
رمضان لهذه السنه فاصل بين الشتاء والصيف
شعبان شتاء شوال صيف بما يسمى بموسم
الربيع والعرب يسمون الربيعه صيفا ومنه
قولهم الصيف ضيعت اللبن والربيع له بدايه
وله شده وله نهايه فبدايته مع موسم
العقارب الى ادخله العقارب ترى الخير قارب
وشدته مع موسم الحميمين ويتزامن مع جرام
خامس ربيعا طامس ونهايته مع موسم الذرعان
وخلال هذه الايام يدخل علينا موسم الاذرعه
ومدته 26 يوما وله ذراعان الذراع الاول
تعرف من حوض الربيع والزراعه ثاني تغرف من
حوض الصيف وبانتهائه نودع الربيع بجميع
مواسمه لما دعا في الركب داعم الفراق
لباهما الدمع من كل ماء يا دمع لم تدعو
سوى مهجتي كلمه تطفلت هذا
سباق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فخلال التسعين يوما القادمه تبدا درجات
الحراره بالارتفاع التدريجي تباعا مع مرور
الايام وحين ذاك تبدا الدول العربيه في
المنافسه العالميه في الدرجات الاحرف خاصه
العراق الكويت السعوديه الجزائر وليبيا
فهذه الدول الخمس تنافس في كل سنه على
الدرجات الاحرف لولا الدموع وفيضهن لاحرقت
ارض الوداع حراره
الاكباد
شكر الله
[موسيقى]
نختم الرابع كالعاده
الحكومه اليمنيه تعلن عن عمليه التبادل
الاسرع مع الحوثيين في عدن وصنعاء ومناطق
اخرى ولمده ثلاثه ايام
السفير السعودي في اليمن يؤكد بان زيارته
لصنع تاتي في اطار تثبيت الهدنه ووقف
اطلاق النار
انطلاق الحمله السعوديه الثالثه للعمل
الخيري والتبرعات تتجاوز 470 مليون ريال
امانه المدينه المنوره تطلق مختبرا متنقل
حديثا لفحص سلامه وجوده الاغذيه والمياه
شكرا لكم لكرم المتابعه الرابعه انتهت الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات